WOULD BE A RED WAVE.
LARRY ELDER JOINS US NOW.
HE'S A FORMER CANDIDATE FOR
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR, THE ONE WE
WOULD HAVE VOTED FOR, THE HOST
OF "THE LARRY ELDER SHOW" ON
EPIC TIMES.
HAPPY TO SEE HIM.
LARRY, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
WHY DON'T -- YOU LIVE IN A
STATE, TRIED TO FIX IT YOURSELF,
BUT LIVE IN A STATE WHERE STORES
CAN'T STAY OPEN BECAUSE THEY'RE
BEING LOOTED.
I DON'T EVEN HEAR OFFICEHOLDERS
EVEN MENTION THIS.
>> EXCELLENT EPILOGUE AS USUAL.
THREE BROAD THINGS.
THE FIRST IS POLICE.
POLICE IN CITY AFTER CITY,
WHETHER IT'S L.A. OR NEW YORK,
THEY'RE DEMORALIZED BY THE LIE
THEY'RE ENGAGING IN SYSTEMIC
RACISM AGAINST MINORITIES, USING
DEADLY FORCE AGAINST MINORITIES
JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE BLACK.
THEY'RE NO LONGER ENGAGING IN
PROACTIVE POLICING, NOT ENGAGING
IN SOME FORM OF STOP, QUESTION
AND FRISK, WHICH HAPPENED UNDER
THE GIULIANI REGIME IN NEW YORK,
THAT CREATED A DEEP DECLINE IN
CRIME.
EVEN RAHM EMANUEL SAID THE
CHICAGO POLICE WENT FETAL,K
MEANING THEY WEREN'T ACTING WITH
PROACTIVE POLICING.
SOFT CRIME DAs.
GAVIN NEWSOM BRAGGED DURING
COVID THAT HE RELEASED 8,000
CONVICTED FALCONS, SOME VIOLENT
OFFENDERS, TUCKER, AND THE ODDS
ARE THAT HALF WILL REOFFENDED.
YOU HAVE PROPOSITION 47 THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO STEAL 950 BUCKS,
NOT JUST TODAY, BUT PER STORE,
AND YOU GET CAUGHT, THEY WRITE
YOU A TICKET AS A MISDEMEANOR
AND YOU DON'T GO TO JAIL.
PROPOSITION 57, THAT ALLOWS A
BUNCH OF CATEGORIES OF CRIME TO
BE CALLED NONVIOLENT.
THEY INCLUDE ASSAULT ON A POLICE
OFFICER.
I KID YOU NOT.
THAT'S NONVIOLENT.
SERIAL ARSON, NONVIOLENT.
RAPE OF AN INTOXICATED VICTIM,
NONVIOLENT.
AS A RESULT, YOU'RE FINDING A
GREATER CHANCE THAT THE BAD GUY
DOESN'T GET CAUGHT.
WHEN THE BAD GUY KNOWS HE'S NOT
GOING TO GET CAUGHT, CRIME GOES
UP.
IF HE KNOWS HE'S NOT GOING TO
GET CONVICTED OR INCARCERATED,
CRIME GOES UP.
THEY'RE NOT STUPID.
THERE'S THE BREAKDOWN OF THE
FAMILY.
YOU SAID PARENTS, PLURAL, ARE
NOT TELLING THEM TO STEAL.
THAT ASSUMES THERE ARE TWO
PARENTS.
OFTEN IT IS THE PARENT OR THE
GRANDPARENT.
40% OF ALL KIDS IN AMERICA TODAY
ENTER THE WORLD, TUCKER, WITHOUT
A FATHER MARRIED TO THE MOTHER.
70% OF BLACK KIDS, HISPANIC
KIDS, 25% OF WHITE KIDS.
IF YOU ENTER A WORLD WITHOUT A
FATHER MARRIED TO THE MOTHER,
YOU'RE MORE LIKELY TO DROP OUT
OF SCHOOL, COMMIT CRIME AND END
UP GOING TO JAIL.
A YOUNG BLACK MAN IS 8-10 TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE MURDERED THAN
A YOUNG WHITE MAN.
MURDER IS THE NUMBER ONE
PREVENTABLE CAUSE OF DEATH FOR
BLACK MEN WHEREAS ACCIDENTS LIKE
CAR ACCIDENTS AND DROWNINGS ARE
THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE AND
PREVENTABLE DEATHS FOR YOUNG
WHITE MEN.
A LOT OF THIS CRIME IS TAKING
PLACE IN THE INNER CITIES, THE
GHETTOS, THE BARRIOS, WHERE THE
FATHER IS NOT THERE.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW WHY
EVERY REPUBLICAN IN THE COUNTRY
WOULDN'T BE RUNNING ON THIS.
IT'S SO OBVIOUS IF THIS
CONTINUES WE'LL BE LIVING IN A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT PLACE THAT
WE DON'T WANT TO LIVE IN.
WHY DON'T THEY SAY THAT OUT
LOUD?
>> WELL, I RAN FOR GOVERNOR FOR
CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS A ESSENTIAL TENET OF MY
CAMPAIGN, BUT ALL THE MEDIA
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT WAS WHETHER
2020 STOLEN.
I'M HEAR TO TALK ABOUT CRIME,
BAD SCHOOLS.
YEAH, BUT DO YOU THINK 2020 WAS
STOLEN?
I CANNOT CREATE THE FILTER.
ABC, CNN, "L.A. TIMES," WHERE I
WAS CALLED THE BLACK FACE OF
WHITE SUPREMACY, THEY DIDN'T
CARE THAT I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
THE CRIME.
THEY WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT I WAS A REPUBLICAN,
VOTED FOR TRUMP, AND HAD GAVIN
NEWSOM BEEN RECALLED IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A REPUBLICAN TAKEOVER.
THAT'S ALL THEY CARE ABOUT.
REPUBLICANS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
OUTNUMBERED 3-1, AND.
MORE AND MORE OF THIS CRIME IS
TAKING PLACE IN THE SUBURBS,
LIKE BEVERLY HILLS, HANCOCK
PARK.
UNTIL AND UNLESS IT HAPPENS,
WE'LL STILL HAVE THE SAME OLD
POLICY PUSHED THE SAME OLD
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
MAKE THEM DEFEND THE LOOTING OF
7-ELEVEN AND EVERY TURN.
YOU DID THIS.
CAN YOU